I'm warmin the former Labour MP and
brilliant political interviewer once
told me to understand parliamentary
politics in the UK I needed to
understand that they all want to be the
Prime Minister and by they he meant all
MPs with the number of toys challenging
to be our next prime minister now in
double figures with some view no hope as
amongst them it seems Brian was right
but do we really think the next prime
minister of this country should be
chosen by a bunch of upper middle class
male white old duffers who are
disproportionately in the members of the
Conservative Party today at one time
there's more than two and a half million
people in the Conservative Party today
membership is down to around a hundred
thousand if that's democracy in the 21st
century god save us instead maybe we
should have an american-style primary
whereby voters not be a declining number
of Tory party members get to make the
decision well compared to the old days I
mean this is relatively democratic I
mean the party leader election rules
were instituted by a chap called
Humphrey Berkeley in 65 but before that
you had sort of Lord Salisbury calling
in MPs and saying who do you want Wahb
or how old you know and it was chosen
like that and it you know I think said
there was the so called magic circle of
Etonians from which a leader would
emerge until 1907 they still have a
magic circle the ten years I'll give you
with Rory and boys returning but there
are 120,000 members I agree you know
it's a sort of election by gammon maybe
off gammon who know that's terrible
thing to say no I don't mean that I
don't mean that
no but surely brothers that means you
think your brother's gammon baby silly
just by just remaining resonantly awful
is it I'm sorry
well now you've retired right I mean to
choose the you know the the leader of 66
million people by 120,000 old white men
in the southeast is a joke but it's the
joke the system we thought we would do I
mean I it would be better to go back to
the system whereby the MPS chose because
at least they are representing somebody
down to two and then then it's left to
the membership I mean we all know if
boys gets to the last two he'll win it
he'll win it because the membership is
more right-wing them that the most of
society I have to say before we get to
the whole kind of complicated businesses
I I'm finding it hard to get past the
range of runners and riders and I just
would like you to take a look at what
the Conservative Party has to offer us
as candidates for prime minister to have
had the opportunity to serve the country
I know
[Music]
fairness for me that word means cutting
taxes for the lowest-paid hi this is
Rory I mean now in the slightly of
serviced settlement Kew Gardens I'm
running to be the next prime minister
because I found Lee believed that we
need a leader for the future not just
for now
[Music]
I'm ready to deliver brexit I'm ready to
take Britain out of the European Union
I've got the steel enos to deliver that
the heart and the courage to do it and
get the strong team that will be needed
to deliver it I think we need the white
type of leadership there's someone that
can promote unity that can bring people
together my own absolute core is a
combination of being a decisive person
gets things done
[Music]
there are three reasons that I need to
be Prime Minister I don't care how you
make a choice but isn't that the
scariest apprenticeship lineup you've
ever seen in your life I mean honestly
it's just the best particle to do now
you're being a bit unfair
not at all maybe a bit unfair there's
obviously no hope is one or two people
have done quite good jobs in quite big
jobs but to hand that wishes with the
argument I make into hand who which of
those becomes the prime minister because
I can't do it now no no before you
asking the electorate they will
obviously if you happen to be a Labour
or green supporter what part you been in
this afternoon you'll vote for the
clinker weren't you so just for the
purpose of debate Nick Ferrari sense
right everybody vote because then
they're like it can't work it can't work
from where we are now but you could have
you could have a better sister always
vote for the idiot they did it before
and they got Sarah Wollaston who
actually has gone off to change the UK
she still does she stood as a Tory but
she was the local doctor and they took
point is that the problem with the
primary system is that in our system as
point people made the point that the
president gets elected by universal
ballot so the primary system sort of
makes some sense there but the problem
for us is that if you have a primary for
the leadership of the Conservative Party
where does that person get their
authority from is it from a ballot of
all sorts of people who are not members
of the Conservative Party or is it from
their MPs I mean I sort of see where you
want to go here what but it doesn't you
it doesn't make sense I just what our
market has got the worst of all world
you're handing the decision for who our
next prime minister is to a bunch of as
you say old white but surely the Empress
out short of the answer to that you said
it
Phil the real answer to that is that the
Conservative Party itself like the
Labour Party has to revive itself so it
has a wider range of members that's the
answer to your problem not to give the
dis if you I'm looking up but but
there's no suggestion I think that
you're gonna get a massive I mean if you
go back to 1940s and 1950s you had
enormous numbers of people in political
parties haven't got it anymore you're
not gonna get it my first point is I'm
astonished that so many people have put
themselves forward for this job because
I what if I was in his party in MP I
wouldn't put myself forward right now if
you paid me triple my salary to pick up
this mess because I don't see anyone
that's going to pick up the situations
that it's today and come out of it
particularly well I agree with you in
the sense of it does seem bizarre that
130 or 140 thousand people whatever is
can choose who the Prime Minister is
because you mentioned Authority and
whoever gets elected they're going to be
constantly having their authority
undermined because of that exact reason
and I don't understand where and how we
can whoever becomes the leader and by
the way I do think that there's some
good ones and I think it's a bit harsh
is to say that they're all Nazis I think
there are a few food ones in there this
will be interesting I don't mind
James cleverly he very recently came out
with his hat in the ring I don't mind
Jeremy Hunt because I respect his
business acumen from outside of politics
I think I knew I'm gonna stone
controversial maybe but Sajid Javid I
don't mind him so I don't think it's as
easy as just and I also I think to give
them some credit people like Rory you
know he's out and about doing his
Twitter lives and if authority what
happens is we have a leadership election
and then the new leader immediately
wants a mandate so bloody cause the
general election as you heard the
breaking news
what yeah Chris Grayling had to throw
but he threw his ring in the Hat
[Applause]
to really make that fun I'll just say to
all my friends who are on that list it's
a joke mate